Chloe Middleton was young healthy and
had everything to live for
but none of that offered any protection
against the deadly coronavirus her
family say Chloe's death should serve as
a dire warning to others writing on
Facebook her mother Diane said to all
the people out there that think it's
just a virus please think again this
so-called virus has taken the life of my
21 year old daughter
Chloe's Aunt Emily mystery wrote my
beautiful kind-hearted niece Chloe has
passed away she had no underlying health
issues please please a dear to
government guidelines the virus isn't
spreading people are spreading the virus
in Chloe's hometown in Buckinghamshire
we found youngsters out skateboarding
and trying to keep a safe distance but
one 18 year old who didn't want to be
identified told me he knew others who
are simply ignoring the ban I know a lot
of people who are going out who are not
really listening to the news but they're
keeping a distance so but staying at
home for like three weeks I don't think
it's going to happen for anyone you're
going to get bored youth leaders are
appealing to youngsters to take the
threat of coronavirus seriously young
people do feel that with them being
young that they might be not as
susceptible to it and my message to them
would be just think about others think
about your older family members even
younger siblings or who might have
health conditions because you could
potentially just go out and end up being
a carrier and passing it on to someone
and it could result in unfortunate
circumstances in Northern Ireland
another stark warning it's not just the
elderly at risk this is 40 year old mark
McClurg a pastor in intensive care this
corner pass is deadly I was dangerous
whoever's wants to kill you whilst I
take all the life out of your lungs so
wide you can't even pray mark McClurg is
continuing his fight against the disease
others are losing the battle the Foreign
Office said British diplomat Stephen
dick died from coronavirus in Hungary
those grieving and those suffering all
testify to one thing whatever your age
all your background ignore the warnings
at your peril Lisa Holland Sky News